merci la parole est à Madame Catherine
de roche pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement
populaire merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre le constat est là et
tous les intervenants précédents l'ont
dit l'exercice de la gynécologie
médicale se heurte à une difficulté qui
est le manque de praticiens vous avez
répondu aux interrogations sur votre
volonté d'augmenter le nombre de postes
d'internes ouverts à cette spécialité
j'ai ajouterai également toutes les
formations postinnat en clinica et et en
praticien hospitalier not si on veut
poursuivre la formation des des futurs
internes mais je souhaiterais pour ma
part aborder la notion de partage des
tâches vous l'avez un peu évoqué dans
vos réponses cet argument a souvent été
évoqué par le passé pour justifier le
blocage des ouvertures de postes certes
les médecins généralistes peuvent
assurer la prise en charge des patientes
même si la formation n'est pas
totalement équivalente mais sur le plan
pratique on sait et l'insuffisance du
nombre des généralistes et la réduction
leur temps euh d'activité effective
quand 100 % des gynécologues médicaux
font des frotties seul 10 % des médecins
généralistes en pratique certes des
gyécologues obstétricien abandonnent
leur activité chirurgicale et
d'accouchement pour réaliser des actes
médicaux mais pourquoi après des années
d'études de spécialité chirurgical
font-ils ce choix souvent pour des
raisons de conditions de travail et de
poids de la responsabilité civile et il
conviendrait d'ailleurs de s'attarder
sur ces raisons certes les sages-femmes
dans le casadre de la loi HPST ont vu
leur champ de compétence élargie mais
sans nier leur professionnalisme je
rappelle qu'elles ne sont pas médecins
les événements récents montrent par
exemple que la prescription de pilule un
acte médical non anodin qui doit tenir
une place majeure dans la discipline de
gynécologie médicale et je n'évoquerai
pas le cas des pharmaciens ou des
infirmières or en terme de santé
publique le besoin du suivi de la femme
sur le plan gynécologique et dans sa
globalité et de la jeune fille pubè
voire même prépuberè à la femme âgée qui
est souvent oubliée dans les
consultations gynécologiques ou les
consultations des médecins généralistes
sur dans ce domaine-là mérite toute
notre attention j'en veux pour preuve le
rapport récent de la Cour des comptes
sur la la vaccination et contre le le
papilomavirus la Cour des comptes oppose
le coût de la vaccination des jeunes
filles avec le dépistage organisé
systématique encore faut-il pouvoir
organiser ce dépistage et assurer un
suivi régulier ce qui est le rôle des
gynécologu médicaux madame la ministre
ma question est donc la suivante quelle
est votre vision de la délégation des
tâches en ce domaine et puis j'ajouterai
une question d'actualité puisqu'on a
évoqué vous l'avez évoqué vous-même les
pilules le la position prise d'un
déremboursement de la pilule Diane sans
sans retrait du ministre du marché peut
être assez peu lisible est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur ce point madame
la ministre Marie
soltouren merci monsieur le président
madame la
sénatrice in de roche je veux répondre à
aux deux grandes interrogations que vous
avez posé de la manière suivante sur les
transferts de tâches attention
d'ailleurs au mots puisque en
l'occurrence je l'ai dit je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce que nous organisions
des parcours de soins et que une femme
comme d'ailleurs pour d'autres
spécialités l'ensemble de la population
mais que là en l'espèce une femme puisse
être suivie par différents spécialistes
si elle en a besoin ou différentes
catégories de de professionnels de façon
fluide les sages-femmes ne sont pas des
professionnells paramédicales mais elles
font bien partie des professions médical
identifié comme tel même si ce ne sont
pas des médecins mais donc j'insiste sur
la la spécialité qui existe et qui est
reconnue par nos textes aux sages-femmes
elle joue un rôle tout à fait important
le deuxième élément sur lequel je veux
insister c'est que qu'il s'agisse des
jeunes ou des moins jeunes puisque les
femmes doivent être être suivi et prise
en charge à tous les âges de leur vie
avec des problématiques des des sujets à
prendre en considération qui évidemment
évolue depuis la première contraception
jusqu'à la prévention du cancer du sein
qui doit être tout à fait appuyé et et
maintenu y compris pour les femmes plus
âgées puisqu'on sait que le risque est
alors accru quel que soit l'âge de la
vie il est important pour les femmes de
pouvoir compter sur le bon conseil au
bon moment et de ce point de vue-là euh
je veux insister sur le sujet de la
contraception que vous avez évoqué il y
a deux sujets différents qu'il convient
de bien distinguer la pilule de 3e et 4e
génération d'un côté la diane 35 de
l'autre des mesures de nature
différentes ont été prises la diane 35
n'est pas considéré dans notre pays
comme un contraceptif puisque c'est un
médicament contre l'acné qui a été
utilisé en dehors de son autorisation de
mise sur le marché comme contraceptif
cette pilule sera retirée suspendu donc
retiré du marché jusqu'à ce qu'une
décision européenne nous oriente quant à
la façon de déterminer la prescription
éventuelle à l'avenir de ce médicament
pour les autres pilules de 3è enfin pour
les les les autres médicaments pilule de
3e et 4e génération le déremboursement
ne renvoie pas une analyse du risque
mais renvoie au fait que ces pilules ne
représentent pas d'avantage médical par
rapport aux pilules de 2è génération et
donc il n'est pas utile que la
collectivité les prenne en charge il
appartient au médecin en relation avec
sa patiente de déterminer la bonne
contraception au bon moment merci Madame
la Ministre madame de roche vous avez 30
secondes pour respecter le temps global
qui nous est imparti oui je voulais
remercier madame la ministre en effet il
est important de clarifier parce qu'on
lit beaucoup de choses sur sur ces
pilules et il importait qu'on ait cette
clarification que vous avez donné même
si sur les pilules de 3e génération on
nous a dit qu'elles étaient qu'ell
pouvent avoir des indications très
précises sur le plan médical et qui
auraiit peut-être justifié dans ce
cas-là un un remboursement